i don't have any friends here my mom
left
it's like i feel like
stuck here now that she's alone with
binium in ethiopia
ariella admits she doesn't know if this
is what she really wanted i'm not
looking forward to being alone with you
i'm not happy about
it why i'm not happy about it
hey nanny day fans fam it's melicia
you know new beginnings aren't always
easy
and that was pretty clear for ariella
and binyam
on the latest episode of the other way i
don't want to hurt your feelings
but i feel like you don't really know me
at all you don't understand me
but while they were struggling with
change
another couple was welcoming it with
open
arms it's finally starting to feel like
chihun is
stepping up and he does take our
relationship seriously and that he does
love me and the kids
yes surprisingly devin and ji hoon are
in a really good
space i love to chew on them in just a
few
but first let's get into ariella who
reluctantly had to say goodbye to her
mom during this episode
positive thoughts okay
yeah what am i a positive gangster
okay you can't die a positive gangster
that's so cute i love that i'm taking it
thanks ariela's mom
but to be real ariella needs all of the
good vibes she can possibly get at this
point
because the reality of her new life in
ethiopia
plus her mom heading back to the states
is
it's hitting her hard really sad mom
you're emotional because you're having
your baby
because i'm all just emotional say
goodbye to the baby i'm gonna miss
[Music]
miss you can't wait to meet you i'm up
in them and now i'm going to meet
baby yeah the baby the real baby yeah a
little bit
mommy's around let's look at me
okay think positive i don't want to
start crying because i'll cry for the
whole 24 hours
don't make me happy i wish her mom could
stay too
i really do the good news is that she
will be back
once the baby is born so they won't have
to wait too long
say bye bye bye love you we love you
all of a sudden everything feels very
real i don't wanna cry i have started
crying now i can't stop
since i spent most of my pregnancy in
america this is the first time we've
been alone together in four and a half
months
so i'm worried that i'm not gonna feel
the same way that i felt before
come on let's go okay come on
come on everything you'll be okay binium
has been
really sweet and patient this entire
time
but ariela's emotions have him worried
that this could possibly turn out to be
a repeat
of his previous situation he's already
been working hard to try to convince his
family that
ariella won't leave with the baby and
that she's different from his ex-wife i
want to make family with you
i want to be good father i promise
but don't leave me i don't know what's
going on
i'm so confused like i know her like
i love her we love each other
but i feel like i realize maybe she'll
leave
i will make you happy okay binium's
words didn't seem to bring any comfort
to ariella if anything it put more
pressure on her
for all these months and i've really
been looking forward to building our new
life here
but we hyped up our relationship so much
and i don't know if this is
what i really wanted
[Music]
we can fix everything together
okay
[Music]
please don't leave me they have
so much to figure out
all right well let's move on to our
final musty moment
see he looks great
tae young celebrated his 100-day
birthday party
which is tradition in korea and the
little cutie was able to bring
devin and ji hoon's family together in a
really special way hey i'm traditional
korean guy
oh he looks so beautiful
oh devin you look beautiful yeah barry
looks so beautiful
100 day birthday party is a big deal in
south korea
congratulations congratulations
and it feels really good to be part of
this tradition but
i'm a little nervous because today i get
to meet all of jihun's extended family
devon said that she was concerned that
his family
specifically his grandmother would not
accept her and drusilla
because in korean culture it can be
looked down upon to be a single mother
or to have a child from a previous
relationship
come here okay okay wait
your great grandma that's not
[Music]
is having a good old time and the
grown-ups are interrupting
but eventually jihoon just cut straight
to the chase
and asked his grandma the big question
[Music]
is
did you say uh
i'm okay
[Music]
oh yeah yeah
and thank
oh you sweet you know during this
episode
devin revealed that she's only been in
korea
for a week a week
talk about an emotional roller coaster
in that short time
frame she went from staying in this
sketchy apartment
to dealing with jihoon storming out on
her
during dinner and of course we can't
forget when ji hoon
stopped chasing after driscilla
stop yelling at me
you need to go inside currently these
two
are drama free so let's take a moment to
bask in it
one two three experiencing this party
has made me really feel like i'm more
accepted by jihoon's family
[Music]
and i could potentially be like a family
member to them
it's finally starting to feel like
jihoon is stepping up
and he does take our relationship
seriously and that he does love me and
the kids
all right well next week on the other
way i don't know what we're gonna do
i can't live in a place that has no
bathroom and no kitchen
ariella explodes on binium as they are
still struggling to get things together
just weeks before her due date listen to
me shut up i'm not
staying here i told you that i'm done
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et
to stay updated on all the latest news
from our guilty pleasure
i'll see you next time
you